But before that, I I came across a nice
quote from Winston Churchill, and I'm
not a huge fan of the guy. I mean, I'm
not saying I'm I'm against him. I hear
all all sorts of things, but I like
these quotes. So, the first one is he
likened to religiosity or piety in
Muslims to rabies in a dog.
Literally, you can I think it's in his
book River War or River Wars, two volume
when he was in I think Sudan, and he
says, "The more pious a Muslim is, the
more like a dog with rabies." In other
words, piety in a Muslim is like rabies
in a dog.
That's pretty bad stuff, right? For
someone to say that. But, why did he say
that? Just to give you means not he's
not a total monster. After he said that,
he said, "Individual Muslims may show
splendid qualities." I'm quoting him.
But, the influence of the religion
paralyzes the social development of
those who follow it. No stronger
retrograde force exists in the world. If
you Okay, so that's Islam. Now, look at
this quote,
also from Churchill.
Quote, "If you will not fight for the
right when you can easily win without
bloodshed,
if you will not fight when your victory
will be sure and not costly, you may
come to the moment when you have to
fight with all the odds against you and
only a precarious chance of survival.
There may even be a worst case. You may
have to fight when there is no hope for
victory because it's better to die than
to live as a slave."
Okay? I think that's where Europe is
right now. Much of the West, actually.
You had a chance. You could have fought
very easily and victory was assured.
Hungary did, Poland did, Slovakia did,
Czech Republic did.
Easy. They did nothing other than put up
a fence and say, "No, thanks."
You didn't, not you, but your
governments, and now you have a hostile
force living side by side with you, ever
burgeoning, ever growing, just due to
birth rate, to say nothing of ongoing
migration.
So, you will have to fight at one point,
and then going to be much, much harder.
And uh it might
and and it might even be pointless, but
it's better to die, according to Winston
Churchill, than to become a slave. And
by the way, he didn't even this second
part I wrote I read to you,
he wasn't even talking about Islam.
I think he was talking about in in the
context of World War
the first point was about Islam, but the
two still
are
very much interrelated. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire
in the
righteous name.